traffic jams like this are now normal in
Zimbabwe's capital
motorists expect to get stuck for
several reasons among them traffic
lights not working that's because of
electricity cuts that can last for hours
not far from the congestion
these people are making items like
tombstones and kitchen tops from Granite
tired of the constant power Cuts they've
invested in generators and other
alternative sources of energy
if they didn't they'd go out of business
grenades uh it's actually a strong
Hearthstone so for us to cut it we have
to use electricity from Grinders our
polishes and everything so to us
electricity is actually you know the
first thing that we actually need in our
business Zimbabwe's power cuts are
blamed on mismanagement corruption aging
coal plants and more recently low water
levels at the Kariba South power
stations zimbabweans are used to power
outages with some areas having no
electricity for most of the day the
government plans to import electricity
from Mozambique and Zambia and other
countries in southern Africa are taking
similar action Lake Kariba is the
biggest source of power for both
Zimbabwe and neighboring Zambia but
water levels have dropped significantly
because of recurring droughts low
rainfall and an increased use of water
to generate power
Zambia has also started rationing power
and it's affecting businesses here in
the capital Lusaka I was very
disappointed because mainly the products
that we sell here about 80 percent their
Fresh Products and when they get bad to
a small scale or
our business is not yet insured so we
see us get affected
Zambia's government says the power Cuts
will continue until water levels rise in
Lake Kariba
in Zimbabwe leaders have told their
people electricity services will get
better all those here can do is wait and
hope they're right haramatasa Al Jazeera
Harare